this is the island of taiwan a
self-ruled democracy in the heart of the
pacific and tensions over taiwan are
higher than they've been in decades
that's because of how taiwan is viewed
around the world the u.s and its allies
support the island's strong democratic
system but the chinese communist party
insists that taiwan is part of china it
feels so strongly about this that its
leaders have vowed to take control of
taiwan by force if necessary things have
gotten so heated that people around the
world are starting to consider the
possibility of a conflict it is hard to
imagine um
that the taiwan could hold out if it
lost access to food electricity the
internet taking on china in a war is a
very big deal you will be a catastrophic
uh consequence if anything happens in
taiwan there are no indications that a
war is imminent but what could happen if
one actually broke out here's a look at
what a war could mean for the island the
pacific region and the entire world
first let's look at the island it's home
to 24 million people and at about 14 000
square miles it's less than one tenth
the size of california
it has eight major ports and four
international airports and those ports
help connect its high-tech economy to
the rest of the world this right here is
the taiwan strait about 100 miles across
it is mainland china in recent weeks
china staged military exercises in these
regions to show that it could isolate
taiwan
my colleague josh chin says the island's
terrain is both a blessing and a curse
for the people of taiwan taiwan is very
mountainous which is good in terms of
defending against an invasion
it's not so great in terms of arable
land that makes taiwan heavily dependent
on imports to survive since the island
only produces about a third of its food
and just 12 percent of its energy
another potential problem for taiwan is
that 95 percent of high-speed data is
transferred through cables that lie on
the ocean floor
so if china wanted to take the island
offline all it would have to do was use
submarines to cut those cables or launch
military strikes at the landing stations
where the cables come on land so we're
talking about critical shortages if a
war broke out and by the way taiwanese
forces would be greatly outnumbered
according to the pentagon china has more
than one million troops while taiwan has
just 88 000 that's why to successfully
defend taiwan the united states would
most likely have to step in are you
willing to get involved militarily to
defend taiwan if it comes to that yes
so let's zoom out a little wider what
would a conflict mean for the pacific a
war wouldn't just have implications for
the u.s military experts say it would
also affect u.s allies in the region
like japan korea the philippines and
australia to varying degrees the
japanese island of okinawa would play a
key role since it has major u.s military
facilities and is less than 500 miles
from taiwan the u.s territory of guam
would also be crucial since it's the
closest american soil to taiwan and
china and is home to major military
bases further south bases in australia
and the philippines could also
potentially come into play south korea
could also be affected but in a
different way because a conflict could
give north korean dictator kim jong-un
an incentive to launch an attack of his
own for that reason military experts i
talked to think it's unlikely that south
korea would directly participate in a
conflict some analysts believe it's
probably too hard to know who would win
a big war but a recent war game
conducted in washington found that the
u.s and taiwan can defend against a
chinese invasion mark cancion and the
center for strategic and international
studies hosted that war game so mark in
your simulation loss of life would be
significant we haven't done the
calculations yet about exactly what
numbers are but you'd be into the
certainly thousand twenty thousand
casualties casualties and equipment
losses that we haven't seen since the
second world war the war game found that
multi-billion dollar aircraft carriers
would be sunk hundreds of fighter jets
would be destroyed and key military
bases would be attacked while a
successful defense of taiwan could
strengthen u.s position in the pacific
mark says that big picture those kinds
of losses would dent u.s power around
the world it would take many years for
the u.s to completely rebuild
its forces after those kinds of losses
you know that might endanger the u.s
position in other parts of the world in
europe or the middle east so that would
be a tremendous risk as for taiwan there
would be a great deal of rebuilding to
do after such a costly conflict so let's
zoom out even more to look at how
devastating a conflict over taiwan would
be to the global economy
this tiny island plays a huge role in
international business just take a look
at this map of ship traffic in the
taiwan strait 90 of the world's largest
ships sailed through last year the
conflict would most likely shut it down
so you can imagine how that would
complicate the global supply chain even
worse a war could [ __ ] one of the
world's most critical industries
semiconductor manufacturing if bad
things happen all of a sudden
we're not talking about chip shortage
anymore the world loses 90 of that
manufacturing capacity taiwanese
companies dominate the industry
especially taiwan semiconductor
manufacturing company or tsmc their
biggest client apple today taiwan makes
70
of the world's microchips and they are
key to getting our cell phones computers
and even our cars to run smoothly
charles also says chips are needed to
develop and run software so do you think
we could lose our ability to tick-tock
or youtube or zoom if there were some
kind of conflict yes i can tell you that
a lot of vacations you love you feel
like it's part of your everyday life
they're gone
there are all kinds of products and
innovations that a chip crisis would
just derail electronics but also things
like healthcare products and renewable
energy parts in the event of a conflict
we may not be able to get any of them so
what would it cost to make taiwan's
semiconductors somewhere else charles
and other analysts i talked to say it
would take more than 300 billion dollars
and at least three years just to
replicate taiwan's semiconductor
industry clearly a war would come at a
heavy cost for taiwan the pacific and
the global economy and that includes
china which is also dependent on
taiwanese semiconductors and trade just
like the rest of the world